[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation I am
dragging this out till we get to the
15-second mark so that way you can get
away with a slight inappropriate
language I feel like I'm almost there
with a little warning bumper sign just a
gentle press there's something I got to
say and that is America's ass t-shirt
that is America's ass real reject
exclusive over at www.re naations
shop.com is now available and I just got
mine in the mail and of course we offer
a whole bunch of other te's over there
as well one of the absolute best ways to
support the channel CO's got a nip
chills one on with M got this R real
reject R thank you guys so much who have
been buying shirts we have been having
the best sales ever and whenever I see
that it happens it makes me so happy
because you're creatively involved with
them so thank you guys like I came up
with this one myself so thank you ah
we're going to watch genv episode 7
today I'm very excited excited are you
guys excited
verily in general
fly ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead
leave a like on this video that'd be
very much appreciated also subscribe
click the notification Bell to get
notified when our reaction for the
finale is up here on the Chanel full
link 3 AC watch along where you snle
with your own copy with jmv available
for super sex re at our patreon page I'm
sing the brightness up on the TV I'm not
ignoring the camera cover sever things
over there how let's watch long as CL
let's get to
it off me get the off me man
uhoh what I do oh my God it's it's it's
our friend is that really him it's movie
Man mark it is movie Man Mark no he's
climbing up in the world what did he do
though I don't care okay he's
a dude he's been on this channel before
yeah whoa rejects gen V Cannon confirmed
last of us crossover
Andy oh
no it's going to
explode I have a feeling sheno Conor and
movie Men Mark are not long for this
world they are not they are moments away
how long will it take well transmission
occurs through direct contact with
bodily fluids so depending on Andy's
viral Lo can't we make it Airborne yeah
speed it up if an Airborne virus gets
into the Super abled population
it could sprad like wildfire that's the
point that's kind of her goal here guy
kill them all kill them all VA would
want us to entertain anything so
reckless in dea it's a little late in
the day to worry about what VA wants
Edison that's what leads to your death
oh by the end of the episode or the next
10 minutes next episode okay I need to
see you what's wrong with something
happened everything is just so up right
now go to my house fix yourself
something to eat I'll be there soon and
I'll take care of
everything you're taking medication
today yeah take another the medication
is keeping her under control take three
and call me in the morning let it dull
you we need to and be able to embrace
these
powers without the
medication what if she's actually
protecting us the paranoia is so
palpable Victor new protest leading up
to today's town hall with the
historically unpopular and phony
socialist just as new rumors serving
Marvel's new rumors so what do we do
I'll wait for her at her house and then
when she comes home I'll make her tell
everyone everything this is Snappy to go
run back to you let her go alone
she'll just stab Us in the back we trust
her when she's still guys so she can
actually read their thoughts in real
time stay out of her heads damn do you
know what I'm
thinking
I didn't know that like K does sound
very far away right
now thought it was a romantic
gesture you know what I'm
thinking you know she probably can't
help it why are you making excuses for
what a beautiful shot we have to believe
she's on our side ads propaganda
politics and genv and you got to stop
turning into a dude when you want to
make a point to us stop using the
patriarchy to your own
Advantage
kiss I said
kiss you're halfway there come
on cuties yeah I smack Marie's
ass and then change and smack it again
America's ass she's the only way to get
Shetty to expose the woods unless we get
proof ourselves how shed's in the city
all day I got the key to her office no
it's going to go great unless we get it
to someone they will listen to like
Victoria Newman oh
yeah soup lives matter the editing
already is just so much
like it's good commentary isn't it
guys it's a technical term I learn found
assessment I did Rip an entire person in
half my defense he was a puppet at the
time
so did he get a haircut
but maybe you didn't do that because now
I'm destroying the evidence and who
remembers yes I saw Starlight pretty
sure there it is yep it's time for
pleasure okay that is a normal am of
toys true I like options respect we
should add stuff like that to the reject
Nation shop a personal vibrating wand
that's just nipple CH do not answer the
door no matter
what Strang or danger stranger stranger
danger that would be my superhero name
stranger danger I ship them so hard so
broke and cute it's a good thing you
ship them because they're together they
are but I buy it more than most TV
couples okay I just you know longevity
ship I believe in it perpetually till
death do them part which I fear is
coming that some attention filled music
right there oh
secret drawer blue bad blue bad this was
hidden in her drawer the Atlantic Flight
oh no the homelander one oh yeah one of
the most ghoulish moments in TV history
yeah I remember that it's terrorist
right she has evidence that it was
homelander who did this shedy Lily aged
11 oh her parent aged 46 her family was
on the plane yeah lifelong
Vengeance
[Music]
yep shitty shitty shitty great cut you
want me to increase the viral infection
rate let me anday my plans allow Like a
Villain hey man kill them all J alcohol
is the greatest plot
device
yes let's
go oh
no golly it's gross but people pretend
it's good to seem sophisticated mhm mhm
find
vintage hey just handed them exactly
what they
need what did he say about infection
rate there's a Sinister Bill to all this
I think there's a lot of gray framing in
this particular episode yeah yeah I
wonder who directed this it's been
really solid the edit too you're
right the shows always have this blue
aesthetic but it's especially you know
some powerful
[Music]
people a CH with a celebrated bot
psychologist who's now dean of their
little superhero Factory you got 2
minutes you'll want longer that's a good
line I'm sorry this is at the school and
V doesn't know we're estimating about 10
months to make it potent and contagious
enough to get the job done it's getting
harder to hide that's why I need you
what is your plan here I know you
monitor soups team affiliations their
whereabouts you know where to find all
of them even those that aren't under V's
thumb okay take them all out neiz them
once and for all what you're describing
goes beyond neutralizing genocide yeah
full it's genocide you need to stop what
you're doing immediately none of this is
going to bring your husband and daughter
back boom so she's been playing this
like ultimate long game Revenge plan
yeah oh your grandchildren oh one of
your fellow countrymen although I doubt
you travel in the same circles has this
same rage who is she talking about is
there an angry man we know from this
universe have a
coat and a best beard on TV together we
can end it or I could have you arrested
and I don't think you will part of you
agrees with me we're done here wait
pleasure to meet you Dean Shetty go back
to your
school what an interesting flip because
it's like she's been poised as the
villain this whole time and while she's
done some very villainous activities the
greater good of like her loss we know
the soups are awful so it's like we kind
of pulling for that there is a
complexity
oh keep a close eye on her is that
butcher think it's butcher think it's
GNA tie into season 4 I told you think
the finale is goingon to be a big old
collab I wanted you to
know that I was good
today little tiny
ones a don't be creepy man it's so
funny oh my God so
badass you just think that cuz
I'm strong and
mistreated Emma oh
no give me a hand uhoh oh no no stranger
danger no fun Steve it's
melting get back inside bro get back
inside dang AR aren't you going to get
in trouble we're superheroes we can do
whatever we want Magic's loud at
Hogwarts that door locks bro oh he's got
a damn video don't
no kill them all yes oh it's that guy no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
don't let him touch you oh no I am so
concerned right now me too don't love
this part's moving I'm coming I'm
supposed to stay here to uh to wait for
Emma Emma's at the party we're going to
oh this is a big con game this is a big
manipulation game
come on oh just keep America safe hat
okay no there he is don't make this
political show political excuse me
excuse me this kid is very much not an
Aryan
propaganda this is not Tucker Carlson no
not at all what he talking about why is
he on Cameron Coleman he doesn't have
anything new to push until next year
moderating the Newman thing shedy
thought it would look better if an
actual superhero was asking questions
about superhero issues what does that
mean you know when I was a kid I want
wanted to be just like him but after
everything we know about this place you
can't trust them can't trust your own
DAV then I'm just going to tell Shetty
everything you tell me Kate you're the
one on my head well Cameron we hear like
aulan believe that speech aggressive cut
little bit of overlap in the voice over
a super
power
whoa you meant super soldier a weird
moment tough questions the superheroes
and real americ she controlling him from
there what's
happening
this
who cover up $250 per month there are no
up what was the commercial even even now
I don't trust her I need to buy
that you are going to
[Music]
love
Samuel sh sh time to be a hero yeah my
that's my dad Buckle in we got to get
going where's Powers just going out of
control I couldn't tell or is it the
Airborne virus or was somebody in there
something yeah at first I thought it was
Emma I think it's the
virus his Towers it's p he's like
sick
who whoa oh man treating people with
powers like that
oh oh jeez we need to wake him
[Music]
up that woman is getting her ass kicked
yeah seriously she's going to get ripped
apart shut up I thought you said Emma
was here what the oh she's meeting us
later why bring
here oh the fbsa is here to protect
people from superheroes but at your own
Congressional hearing Stormfront
slaughtered multiple people and on a
separate occasion Soldier Boy nearly
killed thousands of innocent people in
Manhattan why were you just sitting back
snapping your gum watching America burn
good questions both those instances
caused a 30% drop of public confidence
in superhumans and the fbsa responded by
actually strengthening protection of
both humans and superhumans alike
leading to a record low number of
violent incidents in both
populations well done around the Tire
crowd got to find Newman tell her what
we know any chance you know a teleporter
no but I can cause a distraction Jordan
what are you going to do don't get
caught yank the tail that girl has just
been a plot device every time you're the
girl who tortured Emma right no no no no
no I just gave her a plat God every
time that's what I'm talking about
amazing oh yeah oh wow superhero
fight hey break it
up yeah get in there
[Music]
bud I would get so distracted by the
distraction I would forget that I have
to sneak in there I have this job to do
but we all saw homelander kill a human
in broad daylight talking about it is he
going to be held accountable the finale
is getting brought up now homelander
should stand trial just like anybody
else and a jury of his peers will deide
that outcome humans aren't our
peers yeah buddy most superhumans are
law-abiding citizens n you don't know
we can find Common Sense Solutions
here you will not control us BL heads up
this is not about control it's right
right look people are passionate about
the issue so am I wow powered mob why is
everyone so angry because they're trying
to limit us take away our power we're
homelander is
[Music]
right the the syllables here miss Newman
um do you have a minute Miss Newman
please it's important that I speak with
you you're Marie morau right oh my God
is she the one is she the one who's the
better she must be she must be let's
find some place we can chat just 100%
damn inside source damn I guess it was
John Carlo but John Carlo represented
Victoria yeah it's Victoria got to be
jump am I I drank beer there is this
there was this ice slide I wish you'd
seen it and some of the people here are
bag but they're my friends now we got to
hide you it's okay we just got to hide
you oh no he feels
accepted oh yeah bye best friends oh no
totally not manipulating me no don't
forget where you came from dude I've
been trying to call you for hours I'm
sorry my meeting went long Kate don't do
anything
rash Kate gloves are off not been taking
your medication Kate you know what
happens when you don't all those pills
ever did was make me numb you talk
manipulate that's all you've ever done
to me that isn't true I'm glad you're
taking a stand but don't kill her yet
it's almost time to leave this place
you're leaving me no like the Mortal
coil this place we are leaving after
I've tied up a few loose ends then all
of the sacrifices all of the hard work
she's tricking you don't trust her
that's that manipulation you're talking
about you want to make us sick you no
I'm going to keep you
safe don't let her do it every day I ask
myself why am I still here I found
something truly special again a girl who
was just as lost and lonely as I
felt oh God she so wants to believe in
good oh what do I what do I believe yeah
I don't trust her she she doesn't love
her no she's lying everyone's full of
don't do it you're telling the
truth she can read her mind the things
my true but I don't think one last push
from you and then we can leave all of
this behind you will never be alone
again just kill your friends Kate yes
just one last time we'll hide out in the
green room until it all blows over out
there otherwise I think they might take
off my
head that's a
reference tell me something about myself
I don't understand you can sense things
and
[Music]
blood
you're a super you're blood there's
compound V in it you're a soup I knew
you could do it good
[Laughter]
job why here give me a life I love that
was like a headless character for
transition
clever oh yeah can she blood Bend too
that's how she blows people I let them
ship you after their adult facility so I
got you want to get
F
yep I know that you've fought for every
thing you've ever got in your life I
know that you're constantly lonely and
you're afraid that you're going to hurt
people these older women always
generalizing
her based off the most obvious
information I also know that every
Friday for the past eight years you've
had fish sticks with pink sauce As a
treat now you're stalking cuz I did too
whoa you grew up at Red River till I was
12 I still can't have fish it's residual
trauma just like the smell alone is
is there's a secret lab under the school
where they experiment on kids they're
infecting them with a virus that can
kill soups virus are you sure oh man
there's a doct cardosa he he works in
the woods he knows all about it oh God
this is so complicated no I think I
trust her such a for boing feeling
Victoria Newman yeah but in this in this
instance like for this situation I have
a platform now where I can help people
no she doesn't get it Marie Maro
guardian of gulkan is marketing okay the
first black woman in the seven she has
real power she's friends with the vice
president that's why I trust her cuz she
wants her to survive enough yeah to pass
Marie you have to choose enemy of my eny
can't have both but she's still sending
Marie down a villainous path but in this
moment greater good is to keep like I I
think she wants her in the seven
[Music]
enough Kate told him the plan called her
the plan you're right what happened I'm
okay and now she'll do whatever we want
it's a lie it's totally a lie you don't
have to do this I love you I know you
love me it doesn't change the fact that
you're a
oh this school is a front Thomas gulin
was a behavioral scientist he built this
place to figure out what makes soups
tick sh okay okay you're not here to
study the school is here to study
you s very clear she wants to make it
more contagious she wants more than that
I want it to spread across the globe and
kill all of you oh my god wow what's a
lie what's the truth who side is who are
has she practiced
arleny homelander he took down that
plane he kills your family family you
all leave a path of Destruction behind
you look at what you did to your parents
jeez ra it in lady you're going to get
killed tell them what your last
assignment was for me kill everybody in
the woods wow she wants to wipe us off
the face of the Earth they all do so we
have to strike first
oh that proves their whole point and
then
it's shut the Kate andir oh not mom
anymore it's
time oh she's got to
make oh
yeah didn't think that make it the end
oh but she can fix it she can fix it oh
she can't fix it nope not not what did
she just command this is the only
way oh my god oh no overpower you have
to let me save her I'm so sorry you have
to relive this
oh
manly this is so cruel oh I think Kate
was telling the truth guys I think she
might have been yeah no she she pushed
all of us to believe her that's what
happened do you know what you've
done Justice oh no it can survive for a
few days at ambient temperature but you
want to get this Tas tubes into co-
storage sooner than later NIH will know
what to do oh he's in the Marvel
disu maybe I don't trust her again you
and I
we have the same goals right sure nah
she she going to blow your head up dude
can you get me and my family out before
things take a turn already taken care of
is this all of it yeah you're the only
one who knows how to replicate it right
you're dead now you going to oh there
yeah you're a 21st century American hero
Dr
Cardoza
yeah so
white oh oh you must be a little dry oh
yeah off
off oh oh I love they solved a mystery
from a boy's episode in this like from
forever ago
that's damn damn heads of heads will
roll that was well directed Man very
well directed
people America's as
reation shop.com just saying
guys they mentioned him here amen
mention him here wow wow the Frau
paranoia was just incessant here I I
could not I never knew what to believe I
never knew who to believe I never KN was
like the paranoia was just just Dreadful
on all accounts I think it's like
offscreen Development I've never
appreciated more so now that normally
normally I don't like offscreen
development stuff but that cut to and
Kate and uh what's her name SK
riched K anded I'm getting better guys K
I just have to make my wether when Kate
and Shetty are are there in the room
like oh my God they had a conversation
off screen I don't know which one the I
don't know what like the there's just a
hyper hyper anxiety
episode uh it made me want to believe
Victoria Newman yeah it was so
manipulative I was like please someone
be on their side no man Victor Newman
bad she bad but I hope she good to help
them because temporarily good no she's
so bad she bad that's the one thing I've
learned from everything in this show is
that anybody above the generation that
these kids are directly in are they're
bad people bad what a great reveal uh
that it was her who got her in there
that just makes so much sense and I I
forgot that she her powers not
specifically blow people's heads up it
is a blood control Power which i'
forgotten that they set up the powers
from Marie in the boys yeah I should
should just put girl I was like oh yeah
her only Power is just blowing people's
heads up but no there's a way that gets
there which I did not put together
either when like she had the same Powers
I'm like I'm an idiot yeah it felt like
a revelation from The Boys Like That
season two yeah it's so obvious it's way
too obvious that's what's great is I
love when it twist is so like damn it
yes yeah absolutely also like we're
getting a season two of this so it's
going to be boys dealing with the
ramifications of that virus and then
going into the further ramifications of
theoretically the seven being revealed
like what's what's a god you school
after the seven revealed not to be great
yeah like so this I I keep saying what a
great all year round show have this half
the year that half the Year this half
the year just like cycle deeper into the
world of the boys it sounds like what
they're going to do at least by their
key or somebody was out there
saying gen V will feed into the boys
season 4 the four will feed into gen V
season 2 and you know they'll just hand
it off I think he said it's a handoff
shared universes Done Right looking at
you other shared universes well they do
such a great job at painting out the
psychology of our characters like it
makes sense whether or not you agree
with the choice of even someone like Sam
siding with you know he was alone
manipulated and tortured yeah
not these Trump people pretty malleable
yeah yeah not these Trump people M don't
worry guys don't worry I got it covered
rall I'm I'm keeping it real subtle I'm
keeping away from the politics of it
that the show is cleerly not comic books
Never Been political especially this
show no and it makes sense why Kate
would ultimately do what she's doing
like at the end of the day she really
believes she was doing the right thing
and these are the people who are the
most who who suffered the most at the
hands of ski alri here yeah ski damn you
and and because of that like yeah they
would feel like vengeance is due and
they would feel the most like we we have
to have an uprising sure because look
what these these humans do to us they
torture us they control us they
experiment on us when we have all the
power and we deserve to take back the
power like I get it I I get it may do I
agree with it absolutely yes speaking as
a person who identifies as powered by S
misunderstood by Society yeah know that
was that that was just really well
executed on all fronts and oh why did
Sam have to step outside damn it Sam one
rally one rally Chang just I mean he's
like the literal clay for that exact
thing I love that they set up his anger
I love that they set up his fragility I
love he was literally hiding in a closet
of like trying to be isolated and then
soon as someone's nice to him he would
be like oh my people and and that ju
opposing what she's gone through like
Emma being scorned but also being a
strong person for IT like she's had the
time to build up her sense of self and
like what she believes in so they're
having diametrically opposed views does
work but also they had a lot of the
similar upbringing to the point where
they would have a bond not upbringing
but uh isolation and and I I just love
how much like X-Men the powers represent
the fragility of the human psyche like
what their external power is is their
internal trauma and the show's done a
really good job of making the internal
trauma externalized through actions
powers and the consequence of the boys
and it's all interlaced with real world
issues which is what Comics do best I
think and the way they handled shett in
this episode I thought was very
impressive because the entire series
you're just like is a
you're manipulator and then and
then you but no you learn about the
family you learn about
and then you know she's telling the
truth to Kate as well andand thing is so
diabolical that that we remember that
emotional reaction to like fall that
that was one of like the most like
grippingly harsh Grim moments in t i i
vividly remember seeing that plain
sequence and being like kind of
disturbed by the best episodes of
Television period and and I I will admit
this show is so good it made me go back
and rewatch The Pilot for the boys cuz I
was like man is it that I love what the
boys has grown and flourished and all my
experience with it or has the boys been
great from the jump can report from the
jump that pilot is but I just had to
know and that's how good they show is
that it's making me go back and like
I've seen the first couple Seasons twice
yeah it's a really great show my
girlfriend's never seen it so it's cool
to show her I think I'm going to do
season I'm rewatching it with purpose
but I it's so cool to talk it's not for
me it's cool to talk to got a girlfriend
between episodes it's nice to hear what
she thinks the show is
talk about it anymore you
changed so now that my girl hanging out
with Jack qu so much I wanted to know
what why
you the only three people that have
played supermanman Jack qu
Nicholas the fa Channel but uh it's cool
to talk to her about like the what her
are the show while I'm in real time
seeing the ramifications of like the
[Music]
narrative girlfriend I think it's really
cool to to experience it in a two
timeline way and this show really does a
good job like it referenced a season one
moment a season two moment a season 3
ramification it's really good at growing
the world out so I can share it with my
girlfriend yeah she's great great she
great by the way no and and and I'm sure
your girlfriend would appreciate this
there's a really good she doesn't have a
name they're really good at depicting uh
the sort of generational Clash I feel
like because especially in the moment in
time we live in right now uh it's easy
to kind of look up at all the authority
figures we grew up with and sort of be
like this world is is an ugly horrific
mess in a lot of ways and and you guys
could yeah you guys could do a lot to
depending on your perspective and which
war crimes you're okay with how much
you're willing to expose yourself to the
truth take the red pill and which truth
you're getting the truth from which they
do a great job too no yeah all this
stuff like it like it does again I feel
like the as that was the thing from the
jump it's like is this going to be you
know like really earned in terms of like
how and why they chose to do this as a
spin-off and I think it it so far really
has been nicely that and this episode
certainly kind of gives you that that
sense of like we need to enact a change
all these things are so much bigger than
us and it seems like going through the
proper channels either leads to a dead
end or to like the slowest progress
that's going to be set back along the
way so like what do we do with the mess
of that Victoria Newman has the virus
mallerie told butcher presumably butcher
about the virus that exists so now so
they're going to want to get their hands
on the virus so we're going to finally
have a Newman V butcher
and then but but no but the but the but
the virus would be used on Newman Newman
wouldn't want that virus out there no
but like but they would want to take out
homelander butcher also has compound V
in them does it affect people that have
injected it themselves even
temporarily but he's got he's got
compound V in in a in a like micro sense
yeah yeah not a also he' sacrific
himself well it depends on how good uh
the doctor did his job and and what kind
of contagion level it is can it you know
find that residue uh or
be fully ve yeah that's a good question
theories
keyword and Easter eggs
break what I didn't really get what
happened but like going back real quick
because like the thing I think they
didn't kind of a like I I like the road
mapap of the Sam Arc it's the one of a
couple small things of this episode felt
a little bit rushed as compared to what
we've done in the past a little bit felt
quite rushed is the one thing that felt
cuz his story has been gradual of a time
and I think what they depicted here in
terms of you know you can already see
the the seeds being sown of his mistrust
of our Core Group here because Emma you
know with his best interest at heart is
trying to kind of conceal him but with
his you know recent Crest into like oh
I'm accepted and this is all so fun and
I've also been to this rally that's
completely convinced me of all this
stuff how many kids in college have that
freshman moment right like just when
they're like I've been this and these
people love me like this I mean we see
it with there's certain things that you
mentioned and you just get trouble on
YouTube but you've seen it recently with
with certain real life War stuff that's
been going on where people read a few
things and then they go I'm very
passionately angry about this now and
they don't really get all the
information a lot of the time not saying
what side what side that's what I mean
you
already whichever side you think he said
the other one topic it is specify what
it is but but you see that and I think
like yes they have a Lish that he is
going to be very susceptible and easily
influenced uh and so I think they
they've planted it it just I think in
context of a shows run time and a rally
and then an episode it feels yeah a
little bit of a
conversation I get why the time the CL
great and this is the penultimate
episode which is usually that big like
oh my God but it would have been nice
maybe sprinkle that little subplot a
little earlier that that and and dude
coming into the office being like I'm
going to give you all the information
you need that really bothers
the rest epod I was like what would I
have done differently you need it like I
get it but at the same time I was like
wo Exposition guy it's a functional
scene but it is the one thing I'm like
you're oh you're I'm allowing this
because there's like kind of funny stuff
happening but you're better than this
yeah gen V you're better than this
because the rest of the series I'm like
I wouldn't change that or that and then
this episode's like okay we got to have
them get this information this guy's oh
he drinks in the room okay sure why not
pe's in the thing cuz it it it serves
enough purpose that I forgive its Sill
weird cuz it's it's that thing of like I
feel like this show for the most part
has been well paced and proportioned and
now I'm like should we maybe have done
like nine I think yeah I think Nine
episodes been kind of but I think they I
think what they um managed to hide a
good amount hide whatever flaws on upon
reflection are it they they hide it with
great um intensity dude I've been
sweating the last few episodes they get
my pals they they hide it with great
like just like fastpaced dread how I put
it because yeah I was I was gripped like
the the editing is super sharp here and
you both mentioned the music and the
editing and and every time you pointed
it out it hadn't been distracting but it
had been so good that as soon as I
listened for it I was like oh right
that's why I'm G like it's really good
at being subtle until it's like it's
like a drum beat that just gets faster
well it kept making me think of
heartbeat CU like I was thinking of like
her blood powers and then her singer
blood Powers come with the third beat
John uh I said drum beat you said
heartbeat oh um come ONN pop it off on
you know uh beat by drinks beat
Nicks that that beat Nick energy you
know that sort of off the cuff uh you
know a tonal flow it still works you
know I respect the little carow action
cartion there is the carow action of it
all and it's an episode that's rich with
development like as much as those those
things I had those gripes it's like you
still get like a bunch of big satisfying
we're not wasting time or dottling kind
of development you don't know who to
trust and you also fear for the choices
that that characters are going to make
yeah you see the the kind of comp
they've drawn a nicely complex sort of
ecosystem of like oh these actions are
like kind of good in a in a microcosm
but this is going to be a whole mess you
even for Kate like you don't think she's
a bad guy at all uh but you're also like
I don't know what choice you're going to
make though yeah Victoria Newman is so
good I kept trying to forgive her for
the things I know she's done I kept
being like I want someone to like here
but that's part of the complexity that
the show plays with its audience it's a
it's a little bit of four with the
audience I think I totally agree of like
well we don't want that virus to get out
because we actually like our super
protagonist in this
show but but Victoria no we know that
she can also do bad like it's it's
there's the complexity there of like yes
we want this to be stopped but do we
want Victoria Newman to be the one with
this information right now also we don't
want we don't want them killed we want
them to be held accountable and like
while homelander is killing people in
public we do want there to be some sort
of like ramification and it's it's Jesus
and then also seeing and what I liked
about the town hall meeting too is that
like while it was predominantly against
Victoria Newman you would get the voices
in the crowd who are soups like the
siren girl who is very much still like
not part of that rally that that that
angry rally uh who was who she's the one
voicing like homelander should be held
accountable for what he did you know and
like a fight breaks out amongst people
there and they're all soups so yeah this
is all very fascinating stuff and then
like the revelation of course that God
you is actually a uh the whole time it's
not that there's a secret facility it's
secretly a school yeah exactly like
we're studying them the students I think
that that's excellent stuff now what it
needs to do is in the finale get rid of
all of its nuance and I need either a
space portal some gry minions and lots
of punching big fight yeah big fight and
less of this talking you think we're
going to get a homelander cameo uh I
think we're going to get at least the
boys like the boys and and we might get
homelander and and like uh a couple
soups from the but I I think we might
get like so you think we're going get
the boys homelander and a couple soups
train I think homelander runs through
someone again cyclical I think yeah no
but I think either like home uh Butcher
and the boys or homelander or both I
feel like we'll get a homelander cameo
yeah yeah it'd be a big Pop I mean
homelander is like the mascot and would
be a great I think conflicting character
to throw into the mix with everybody
yeah and especially now that our our
main protagonists know like no
homelander is actually truly evil yeah
for the ey line I think it's more impact
I mean dep on what they do but it could
also possibly tease it a potential
Alliance great way for you know a mega
Corporation to use their iconic figure
to make sales up on their show VA
Amazon yeah sure it it works like use
the corporate imagery like you're saying
he's the he's the mascot that might sell
even more than the leads of the show if
you have the iconography oh yeah
homelanders coming back I mean yeah in
in certain ways I mean it is sort of the
homelander show I me and and two like
not exactly kind of piggybacking off
that I think this will be interesting
because I could foresee a version where
this leads to a lot of messy like as
much as I'm like yeah the boys would
love this I'm also like you know though
like it is like diabolical what it is so
I can see some really nice kind of
conflicts coming out of that yeah I
don't think you know like I don't think
would be down I think be like let's
murder
mm you know even might might like yeah
like as much as I got reasons to hate
these people too like yeah yeah I can't
wait no one should have that power no
one man no one man should have all that
power yeah Beats by Dre or the beat next
by Dre uh that said I do hope uh the
strike uh you know everything gets
pushed with the boys hopefully we know
Season 4 soon because I I do think the
finale is going to leave us with like a
for the boys like I think it's going to
be just shy of a cliffhanger for season
4 and I know there kryp key already said
like this this isn't coming out until
everything's resolved so yeah what an
this guy fighting for union
rights scab for us man doesn't he know
who he works for Industries what are we
paying Amazon to pay you for yeah $9
certainly pays all of you well I'm not
worry my homelander costume this
Halloween yeah I've been told not to
yeah but I will be West they're going to
come to every Halloween party make I'm
just going be homelander from the comics
police exactly yeah exactly get make it
put some like uh find a way to put like
a thick outline around you so that it's
clear that you are pencil drawn and you
the comic I'm going to dress as young
Simon Peg and only comic fans will know
that I'm we huy from the
comic shave head head a little bit boom
talk an accent guys what are your
predictions for how the finale is going
to go down please go ahead leave your
thoughts down below uh leave a like on
this video subscribe get yourself an
America's ass t or anything from the
reject Nation shop links in description
box and pin comment thank you John for
being here thank you Coy for being here
thank you for thank you for watching
peace out reject
[Music]
Nation